covid-19 cases are surging again around
the world some countries have reimposed
restrictions they've just lifted so
what's behind this rise in infections
and what should we expect this is Inside
Story
[Music]
[Music]
hello welcome to the program I'm Rob
Matheson covid-19 cases are on the rise
in more than a hundred countries the
Omicron variant dominates those
infections it's two main mutations known
as B point four and B point five are
harder to track and resistant to
vaccines the next few months are going
to see an increase in Global Travel as
Millions take their summer holidays and
that's likely to increase the spread of
covert 19. those in the pandemic hit
tourism industry were hoping to recover
this season as restrictions began to
ease in many places but that could
change the head of the World Health
Organization says the pandemic is not
over
driven by ba4 and ba5 in many places
cases are on the rise in 110 countries
causing over all Global cases to
increase by 20 percent
and deserts have risen in three of the
six who regions even as the global
figure remains relatively stable
this pandemic is changing but it's not
over our ability to track the virus is
under threat as reporting and genomic
sequences are declining meaning it's
becoming harder to track Omicron and
analyze future emerging variants
or restrictions are coming back in some
places and they could again become part
of everyday life Italy has extended the
need to use masks on public transport
until the end of September Germany and
Ireland are thinking about making them
mandatory in a few months and the new
variants are more resistant The Who and
several other organizations are
encouraging more vaccination campaigns
and booster shots China has maintained
some of the toughest restrictions but
other countries have been easing them
and if cases continue to rise we may see
a return to government imposed lockdowns
and stricter contact tracing everywhere
okay let's bring in our guests in Rabat
we have azadin ibrahimi he's director of
Med by attack and professor of medical
biotechnology at Muhammad V University
in Barcelona Jeffrey Lazarus is head of
Health Systems research group at
Barcelona Institute for Global health
and in Mumbai Dr ishwakalada an
infectious disease specialist and
Secretary General of the organized
medicine academic Guild a warm welcome
to you all thank you very much indeed
for being with us Dr Galata I want to
start with you are these spikes that
we're seeing mainly down to countries
opening up or is there something else at
play here
uh you see we just heard what Dr Tedros
was telling from who now what we are
looking at is only increase in number of
cases but we are not looking at the
trajectory how many of those cases
require oxygen how many of them are
landing up in hospital how many of them
require ICU and how many of them are
dying if you look at the global deaths
till today in last two and a half years
it is 1.2 percent of the total cases
that is called case fatality rate but
currently with omigram that has come
down to 0.1 percent to 0.2 percent that
is one in Thousand to two in thousand
and that's why the Omicron variant I
have been labeling for last several
months as a variant of support rather
than variant of concern uh if we look at
currently yes there is a surge in cases
but mainly surges in USA North Korea
Taiwan France Germany Italy and UK and
they are very small in population as
compared to India like for example
France is about 0.5 5 percent of India's
population but reporting 10 times more
cases so there is some problem there
and ba 0.5 is more important there
suddenly when India we have seen
yesterday that ba Point ba 2.75 which is
a new sub variant has been detected just
only yesterday and there are so many
cases but all these subarians whether it
is a ba 0.2 or ba 0.45 they are highly
infectious but they are not lethal they
are not killer they are not giving you
morbidity and mortality both so by that
way we are not doing bad and I don't
think that lockdown situation will come
back again I don't think that many more
restrictions will come back again
you were nodding all the way through
that is this situation that we're facing
now very different to the situation that
we were in when covid first came to pass
well actually I agree with my friend
from India I think what we are saying in
Morocco actually is the same situation
we have higher infection rates in the
Rock right now but when we look at that
hospitalization and the death rates the
numbers today is actually very limited
and the numbers are really same so I
think what we are looking at I think the
the highest problem we got we got it
with Delta I don't think that I'm
comparing to micro that's comparing last
year at the same time in Morocco we have
the Delta and the Delta we had the high
infection and the high rate mortality
and hospitalization in Morocco right now
we have really uh very strong uh pick
FFA I may say of infection but besides
that we don't see hospitalization or
that we are not looking at the same
virus almost I have to say that and I
have to say that comparing Delta to ba4
or 5 actually we we are not looking at
the same virus almost so I think
strongly think that the approaches
should be changing and to talk about the
covet I think we are not at March 2020
but we are at June or July 2022 and lots
of things are changing Jeffrey Lazarus
um according to our first two guests my
impression is that things are actually
improving that things are getting better
is that your interpretation of it are
the things that we should be looking at
I'd like to agree and obviously we have
the you know people with fewer severe
symptoms fewer deaths because the
vaccines are working on the negative
side I mean the elephant in the room is
really long coveted persistent symptoms
occurring after four weeks and for some
people after three months six months and
not just fatigue
um sore throat and cough but you know
serious symptoms that can even be
permanent like thinning of the brain
membrane and reduced lung capacity we
also have concerns that there's waning
immunity with the third dose the fourth
dose they say is maybe waning even
faster than the third dose and hasn't
been rolled out everywhere yet
um and my main concern really is that
we're not preparing for the future waves
and there will be future waves
um ba1 infection with that sub-variant
is not protecting us against reinfection
with pa4 and five and it's hard to know
what's to come as Dr tedro said um a few
minutes ago you know these are hard to
track and it's going to be very
important to keep sequencing more and to
build laboratory capacity in countries
that haven't been able to sequence so
much to date
um
the the point that Professor Lazarus is
making there is that we may have reached
a situation where
um covet at the moment is managed shall
we say but there are longer term impacts
particularly with reference to say long
covert and how we approach the the um
the dealing with any particular variance
variants in the future what do you think
are the risks and the concerns with
regard to Long covert
uh what Professor Lazarus says is right
that long kovid is a major issue we do
not understand completely what is long
covered how many people will get it who
will get it whether only symptomatic
people will get it or even asymptomatic
people will get it but what we have seen
over the year one and a half year or two
years is that those which were in the
first and second wave till last year
June uh they got covet they are having
long coin problem we have not seen much
of the people with Omicron wave they got
covered and they are getting long
covered maybe because in the Omicron
wave we are seeing mainly upper respect
attack infection and that is only a
fever sore throat a little bit lethargy
and cuff and little headache but lower
part of lung is not involved pneumonitis
is not there
therefore the oxygen requirement is low
so possibly those who required oxygen
those who landed up in hospital those
who landed up in ICU or the kind of bed
with ventilator they may be facing more
problem with a long covet secondly what
we have seen
those people with comorbidities may be
hypertension diabetes aging renal
failure a previous lung problem
tuberculosis they are facing more
problem with long covet so we need to
understand what is long covet and that
is a precise reason that even though
Omicron is a milder variant as compared
to previous variant we should be very
careful about long covet and what will
happen in next six to eight months
do you think that that means that the
the stresses and strains that we saw
being put on the world's medical
facilities aren't going to go away that
this may be a pause until as Dr Gallardo
was saying and Professor Lazarus that we
begin to realize that the longer term
impact of something like long covered
well I agree with my friends actually
the long coffee could be a problem and
we have to be very cautious but I think
what we are saying right now that's when
the question is so clear that it will be
if there is or will be a stress on the
health system I think it will depend on
the countries because the age will be a
big factor in that and they're thinking
country is like in Africa it's not going
to be a problem because I think now we
know that the recommendation there is
two recommendations that we can make
vaccinating and intimidating people
where older people or Chronicle diseases
like people with diabetes or HCA or
other diseases of this kind and the
other thing is just distancing and
masking I think it will be very
difficult and we have to say it right
now to go and ask the population young
population to be vaccinated right now
because there's people they don't see
the need of that and as we are saying
that the immunity will be going down and
the vaccination will not give you a
really a high immunity vis-a-vis of
other viruses or severins young people
will not be vaccinated Our Hope actually
is actually to go and Target elderly
people people with critical diseases so
that we cannot have actually a big
stress on the health system and you can
understand that in countries where you
have a young population like in Morocco
and African countries I think people are
not thinking about the forward right now
that's mainly thinking about other
problems Jeff Lazarus said the UN said
in May that a billion people are
estimated in lower income countries
hadn't been vaccinated do you think that
governments have become too relaxed or
do you think that people are themselves
are just
well should we say God complacent that
they have just decided that covet is no
longer an issue how do you address that
kind of problem
well it's a combination of both coupled
with what's been a very slow rollout of
of vaccines to low and middle income
countries although that's getting much
better now as people hear that death
rates are falling fewer cases of severe
Sim people with severe symptoms they are
less worried and I'm afraid that you
know policy makers are playing into that
because it's not very popular to
encourage vaccination to encourage
control measures like face masking
inside so but I think they're doing a
disservice to their population also
because um as there's more Transmission
in the community we get more variants
and as we've seen with omicon more
sub-variants and with you know no
protection against ba4 and five when you
have ba1 with ba4 and five more
transmissible I think we need to do
everything we can to slow down the
transmission and slow down future waves
including the current wave Angelina do
you think that the World opened up too
soon
I don't think so I think that right now
we can say it's actually we have to to
have this question is it the end of the
pandemic I think it's the right question
that the population is asking and I
think when we look at the curve actually
how we got with the yuhan virus after
that the alpha I think we had the
biggest problem with the Delta with the
Omicron ba1 actually we have less
problems and actually with the bay too
less problems and maybe the sequels
usually are not that good at the
original version so maybe I'm very
optimistic that we are going really uh
to the end of this pandemic coming back
to to your question I think we didn't
open just because really for health
reasons we opened up for different
reasons I think the recommendation is
not usually just the health
recommendation or the scientific
recommendation but there is the
economics recommendation we were talking
about tourism also that's a plays a big
role but I think the risk that we are
taking route right now if we don't talk
about the long covet I think it's well
taken and I think we have to open up
because we cannot skip up after two
years and a half with this situation
given that
um India was one of the countries that
was hardest hit simply if nothing else
by scale uh in terms of covid-19 and
also India's economy is uh in
difficulties at the moment do you think
that there is a a concern that longer
term if the impact of long covert
appears to be as great as people are
concerned that it will be that the
impact on the country is going to be
significant and we are going to see
India's economy and countries like India
see their economies really begin to
struggle and become under pressure in
the way that we saw at the start of the
outbreak
we say a propose to what uh globally
people think about India
barring two months period of last year
2021 uh April to June India done very
well uh India has done vaccination to
the tune of almost close to 2 billion
vaccines provided it's a 75 percent of
the population is at least one dose and
65 66 percent of the population is a two
doses vaccine India has 11 uh licensed
vaccines in India
um they have vaccine even for children
and India's economy is currently doing
fairly well it has picked up very well
uh there are concern always that when
you open up the cases go up but they did
not go up so much sizably in India to
the width and breadth of the country to
the population of 1.4 billion we have
hardly uh 15 20 000 cases a day maybe
there are more which are not reported
but uh we go by what has been happening
and how many are reported relatively we
are reporting very few cases but there
deaths are very very low every day only
15 to 30 deaths out of 30 almost half of
the deaths are readjusted all deaths so
death rate is 0.1 percent one in a
thousand so by that way
India is doing very well secondly coming
back to the question of vaccination
versus what is the number of cases
psyche and uh globally is that when the
deaths are high when the cases are high
people want to take vaccine actually
speaking that is a wrong time to take
vaccine best time to take vaccine is
when they covid or any infection is
lying low at that time you know that you
are vaccinating people which are not
infected when the pandemic is going up
and at that time you are vaccinating
that means you may be vaccinating people
who are infected or who are incubating
the virus so I think people should
understand one thing uh yes there is a
global inequity but India has come to
rescue India will continue to be at
rescue India can provide the vaccines at
much of the lower price the last issue
is that some of the vaccines have a very
low tail like just four to five months
they give you efficiency uh Pfizer mRNA
vaccine or modern vaccine but as
compared to astrogenica is estrogenic
are done very well and that's the reason
that India having 90 percent of the
people vaccinated
has done well there is a study in
Malaysia where they use three vaccine
estrogenica Pfizer mRNA and synovac from
China and they have seen the outcome of
those vaccination and how many were the
Breakthrough infection how many deaths
out of retro infection what they found
that if one person died of estrogenica
2.5 times more people died of mRNA and
9.5 times more died after synovac so
that means shinovac is useless and as
compared to mRNA estrogenic is far
better so that's the reason that India
probably have has a better vaccination
and now the immunity out of vaccine may
be lasting little bit longer or much
longer than the MRNA vaccine Jeff
Lazarus there was a big push at the
height of the the outbreak uh to try to
give individual countries the right to
license the the drugs themselves and
indeed the the capability of
manufacturing their own vaccines and so
on
um how has that gone because we've kind
of lost sight of whether or not those
programs brands are actually working and
if they are producing the the the
vaccines that people need particularly
of course in the African continent
vaccine production is incredibly complex
so even when you have the license having
the production facilities and all of the
different components sometimes as many
as more than 100 components to make a
vaccine not to mention
um the filling and completion
facilities that need to be in place the
storage the refrigerators and so on so
it is progressing there is Good Will
um but I think the the difference really
has been that capacity has increased or
the availability of vaccines has
increased from high income countries as
people here got vaccinated I think we
need to be thinking long term we need to
be thinking well how are we going to
decentralize vaccination production or
vaccine production more and allow
manufacturing outside of the hubs where
it's been um until to date
uh Jeff do you think that the
governments are actually still
interested in making the level of
investment that is needed either in the
the vaccine production or in terms of
getting people vaccinated depending
where they are in the world or indeed
just creating systems
um to
for example uh systems air breathing
systems within air conditioned systems
within buildings in order to try to make
them better and more suitable to try to
control this kind of thing
yeah so there's a couple of questions in
there so I think
um you know it's going to take a big
investment from high income countries
and you know it's not just about the
covid-19
um vaccine this is an opportunity to
increase production and productivity
related to vaccine production in other
parts of the world now we really need a
vaccine plus
um approach vaccination is not going to
get us out of the pandemic it's not
going to end on future waves or in the
pandemic really as a public health
threat so like you mentioned we need to
improve we need to make structural
changes we need to do two things we need
to be improving the the air qual indoor
air quality and how that works in
buildings particularly the new buildings
we're constructing but we also need to
educate the population on how we can
improve air quality through better
ventilation simple things about opening
Windows opening doors how often they
should be opened and having more CO2
monitors available so people can
actually see the indoor air quality I'm
in their school schools and their places
of work and take action as necessary
because it's not that expensive and not
that complicated to improve indoor air
quality when it's related to opening
doors and windows it is of course when
you're doing major structural changes to
buildings
do you think that were it necessary for
the for governments but the Indian
government to reintroduce mask wearing
to reintroduce uh restrictions within
the country do you think that people
would be as willing to accept those or
do you think that people are now sort of
set in the in in them they have the
mindset that covet is over and there is
no problem and therefore they may be
putting themselves at at risk
uh actually you put on a question and
you answered yourself we don't think the
government is in a mood to put lot of
restrictions now and uh even if
Government introduces restriction I
don't think people will follow them now
what we need to ensure is that people
even they are indoors uh and they are in
crowded places like uh local trains or
buses or public places or theaters they
should use masks we should emulate good
practices and what we see good practices
are in Hospitals and Clinics and start
restaurants and hospitals where
everybody is wearing masks so if we
emulate that culture I think that will
be good for us to prevent even other
respiratory infections tuberculosis uh
problem related to pollution
so I think that will help so that has to
be a culture in people we do not expect
the government to put everything in
order and ask people to do that because
people have done that for two and a half
years they are actually we call covet
fatigue so I don't think any kind of
restrictions are required and they'll be
ordered in either national government or
by the any state government
is it in Ibrahim are we at the stage
where people are going to be required to
have an annual booster for against covet
in the way that they do against other
viruses
well I think scientific
scientifically we don't have the data
actually to say that against ba4 or ba5
how long the vaccine will give us
immunity I think that's question will be
there but coming back to what my two
friends were talking about I think the
pandemic is different from one area to
another I think when we talk about India
and Africa most of the people they are
Beyond actually the pandemic they are
not thinking about masking they are not
thinking about taking the vaccine and
they don't see even the need for that
and definitely when you tell them that
even if you are taking the vaccine you
will be infected people will not
actually get to be vaccinated so I think
there is awareness that we have to work
on actually in these countries and the
other parts of the world I think what's
going to happen mainly people they will
be asking for vaccine of the second or
the third generation that will give you
immunity and that will answer your
question if you are taking a booster you
want to make sure actually that this
booster will be protecting you a couple
of months if not you will not see the
need for it but we can say right now for
the elderly I think what is really left
of the immunity given by the vaccine is
really very helpful for the old elders
and people with the critical diseases
for the younger population I think it
will be tough to convince them to go to
be vaccinated I want to say thanks to
all our guests azerin Ibrahim Jeffrey
Lazarus and Dr ishwar galada and thanks
to you too for watching you can see the
program again anytime by visiting our
website aljazeera.com and for further
discussion go to our Facebook page
that's facebook.com forward slash AJ
Inside Story
you can also join the conversation on
Twitter our handle is at AJ Inside Story
for me Rob Matheson and the entire team
here in Doha bye for now
[Music]